what overtook me was the sheer
excitement of a wide open road in New
York City and I was like I don't want to
run in a straight line over the course
of 100 miles you need to make a
bajillion decisions you need to make
them quickly and you need to not
overthink them and you need to just keep
moving how do you figure out what your
evolution is and how do you have the
confidence to do it I think I know how
to do that do you want to know
Alexi
papis this is a person who knows a thing
or two about what it takes to execute at
the highest level with a light dusting
of glitter on top and today she's back
for a dive into her what I call the
extended bravy Universe Alexi is a
former Olympic truck and field athlete
Greek national record holder in the
10,000 meters but she's also a poet uh
performer a writer and also an
award-winning filmmaker her critically
acclaimed Memoir bravy was a smash
bestseller her feature film resume
includes some variation of writing
co-writing directing Andor starring in
films such as Olympic dreams with Nick
koll and a film called Track Town with
Rachel drach and she's working on a soon
Tobe released new podcast that I'm very
excited about called Mentor Buffet we
discussed her interest in inspiring
women ands girls to fall in love with
Sport Plus a few cool growth tools that
she shares like something that she calls
goop Alexi is a delight she's just a
breath of fresh air with the right
amount of Bubbles and uh one of my
favorite people so without further Ado
please enjoy my conversation with the
great Alexi
papis and ready sight go it's so good to
see you thank you for coming back I'm so
happy to see you and I think the first
time we met met here I didn't live so
close to you so it felt like a more of a
journey but now it feels like you're a
neighbor yeah yeah and we've become
friends ever since then which has really
been fun I was reflecting back on on
your first appearance here a lot has
changed since then um in that
conversation we talked extensively about
not just your athletic career but also
your creative career as a filmmaker as
an author as a writer as a poet Etc and
how you balance those two worlds and
devote appropriate amounts of attention
to achieve your goals and you know to
kind of really ambitious Pursuits that
uh have sort of defined your public
facing life um but it was
also a really interesting moment of
transition for you uh you came in you
were on crutches oh yeah remember that
injured and nobody knew and you were
like I don't want to talk about the fact
that I'm injured because at that moment
you were still technically a
professional athlete yeah as far as you
know the broader world was concerned and
you were trying in real time to figure
out where you were going to head right
like were you going to hang on to being
a professional were you going to let go
of that and have a looser relationship
with running and Go full boore more into
the film making Etc and that was kind of
gestating I think in your mind at that
time and you know now it's it's pretty
clear the decisions you've made and the
the kind of path that you've been
blazing but it wasn't so clear then no
and I remember picking the outfit based
on what outfit would properly hide the
leg brace that I had it was like a full
it was a full hamstring reconstruction
surgery that I wasn't ready to share
about yet and I remember feeling very
safe with you
because I knew that you understood like
the athletic side of life and also the
like kind of public facing side
but I was
scared I was a little you know I don't
know if scared was the right word but I
was very thoughtful about when I shared
what and I think that that's something
that you and I have talked about like
privately about what what we share why
and like what's useful to us and I
remember at that time it like I wasn't
ready to share about the surgery it had
just happened I think and I didn't know
how to talk about it and I think that's
something that we're allowed to have in
privacy we're allowed to like
take the time to figure out what story
we want to tell about ourselves before
we tell it and that privacy can be like
a superpower if you let yourself have it
sometimes sure but I think it's also a
reflection of of what goes on in your
brain when you're a professional athlete
versus just you know somebody else right
like like how are the sponsors going to
you know react to me saying I'm injured
right now what does that mean in terms
of contracts and how the professional
running world is going to perceive me
Etc and now with your relationship with
running it's like who gives a right
like you're doing it for very different
reasons right so those factors don't I
mean you still work with Brands Etc but
they don't come into play in the same
kind of way that they would have had you
been you know kind of trying to go back
to the Olympics for example yes well
it's funny because like when you're a
kid and you break your arm the cast is
like a sign of achievement in a way
right like everyone signs your cast but
if you're an athlete it's a little
you're Kryptonite yeah it's like bad
somebody might catch a break if they
stand too close to you yeah exactly and
the reason why athletes don't share
about that stuff is because we're so
often playing defense as athletes like
you're defending whatever you've done
for most of the present you're like
defending what you did and you're
defending like maintaining a narrative
that people that you want to have about
yourself and so so I think the shift
that I made was it it actually happened
after I don't know when we recorded that
but sometime after that I had a
conversation with Richard linklater and
he said very firmly but lovingly that I
was playing defense about my athletic
career and what he meant was that I was
carrying on a narrative of like maybe
I'll compete in the Olympic like maybe
I'll compete again and he was like it's
time for you to start playing offense
and put out into the world what you
really want to be doing whatever it is
and then see who will go with you and
that shift was so cool because um I
trusted him he was an athlete and then
he transitioned into the Arts and he was
right that we need to play offense in
our life in general and not be defending
a narrative that like might be
Antiquated for us that's so interesting
I didn't know Richard linklater was an
athlete I mean we should point out for
people that don't know Richard linklater
acclaimed legendary
filmmaker Boyhood Slackers I mean he's
made a million movies right um and kind
of a mentor to you right was he a runner
I didn't know that he was an athlete he
wasn't a runner he was a baseball player
that's reflected in some of his movies
and he there were health reasons why he
didn't pursue baseball at like a MLB
level for example but he's an amazing
athlete and when he realized when he
decided to make the shift into the Arts
he you know and he can certainly share
this Sumer self but
he he went and worked in the oil
industry and saved money where a lot of
people I think can stay there forever
which is which is fine and he saved
money to transition into the Arts and
when he felt like he was stable enough
he went and made his first movie and
that might be a really simplified
version of it but essentially he was
playing offense right he was creating a
space for himself to make that
transition and then he made a leap and I
really admire it because it's like it's
hard to do two things at the highest
level in your life but it's fun to try
mhm I think you're doing it you're doing
a pretty good job yeah I think when
you're an athlete or a professional
athlete there's a certain machinery and
institutionalization at play that ends
up defining that narrative for you like
you have to really be extremely
proactive to construct a narrative that
is somewhat a skew to whatever narrative
is appropriate for the times that you're
clocking and the podiums that you're on
or not on right amidst like a circuit of
races that kind of dictate like who you
are in the pecking order of your
particular Sport and you as a writer and
a poet and all the stuff and all the fun
creative stuff that you do like
shouldering that responsibility to be
proactive about creating a different
narrative somewhat inside that system
but also outside of it is a creative
challenge but also it's kind of scary
too because then it's on you and then
you have to be like I just did a podcast
with Arnold Schwarz Ander and he has
this whole thing about sell sell sell
like you have to be in charge of your
own story you can't expect people to see
your story the way that you do or care
about whatever it is that you're trying
to get them to care about unless you're
out in front of people telling them
about it so that's very similar to what
link later is saying like how can you be
in control of that story well I was just
thinking about how people see us right
because people I think when they when
they see us they
see it's almost
like they are making paintings of a
photograph of us like they're creating a
more their own impression of what they
saw or see so people won't grow us up
for us except sometimes like a mentor or
coach right there are people in our
Lives who see beyond this moment for us
but that's not most people most people I
think see you where you are and they see
that repeating infinitely like when a
mirror looks at itself and it's
repeating infinitely and so when we want
to get out of that repeating mirror
we're lucky to have a coach or a mentor
to help us see what the next thing might
be or a best friend or partner but we
are also capable of breaking out of that
mirror image
ourselves by simply taking steps in
different direction and doing it with
full commitment and that's like the main
thing I think is not doing it as if the
ground is made of ice you have to do it
as if deliberately deliberately yeah
it's harder to do without a coach though
and when you're an athlete and you're
used to having somebody right at your
shoulder all the time giving you the
hard feedback all along the way and then
you're suddenly a civilian you have to
seek those people out right otherwise
you can it's very easy to get trapped in
that Hall of Mirrors and then your your
thinking isn't as conscious as it could
be because you're trying to solve that
you know whatever dilemma you find
yourself in with the same mind that that
created it in the first place without
that outside input yes so the question
is how do you figure out what the next
thing is how do you figure out what your
evolution is and how do you have the
confidence to do it and how do you know
what to do in order to get it right
there's those
three things and so how do you do that I
think I know how to do that do you want
to know please explain what I think yeah
this is why you're here I think first of
all all change happens a lot slower than
we think and that's why when people see
people they admire or they read books
about
transformation I think they can often be
misleading and make people think that
change is like a right turn when like
the right turn turn is usually happening
in a series of very very very very tiny
steps and you know you you and I are
close enough friends that I think you've
seen smaller steps of mine like for you
to even see the leg brace means you saw
a small step that people just won't see
they won't see the step where I wasn't
sure about sharing it I think big
changes
happen very very
slowly um and accepting that is super
important because when I see people whip
their life around when they think they
want a big change it usually either
spirals them into depression or it's not
an effective way to actually make the
change or it leaves them with like a
tangible change but not the time to like
emotionally change with it so to evolve
as a person um so that I think is the
first thing then as far as what are you
doing so let's just say you feel like
you need to change then it's like what
is the change where am I headed what do
I do or what is the identity I want to
shift or whatever it is there's been two
things that have been helpful to me that
I'll share one was an exercise that
Deepak Chopra took me through in like
this small seminar that I did and I'm
sure he shared it elsewhere but
basically we were in this room and he
was asking us to ask ourselves questions
without reaching for the answer so in
order
to figure out answers basically you
simply keep asking the question without
reaching for the answer so the question
might be what is my purpose right and
the goal was just to Simply keep saying
what is my purpose what is my purpose
what is my purpose without trying to
reach for the purpose because when we
reach we're often reaching for something
like an occupation or something in the
tangible world and it's too like
contextualized in the world but when we
just ask and like wait it was so cool
because for me what came to mind was
like hugging 21-year-old girls and
saying this is going to sound weird and
saying everything's going to be okay and
like everything's going to be okay and
everything's going to be okay and like
that's not a job but it felt like a
purpose to help people feel okay and it
did feel feel accurate and that felt
like the first step was to pull our
Evolution out of the material world or
the world as we know it and to make it
more of an idea first I love that I mean
I think that that speaks to to trying to
identify the emotional experience to
extend your example of what it feels
like when your life feels like it has
purpose right like if you were living a
life of purpose what what would come to
mind as a behavior or an activity or an
emotion that would evoke that in you and
then you can kind of build on that
almost or reverse engineer how do I get
to the experience where I'm hugging 2
21y old girls and telling them that it's
going to be okay right and you it's
interesting because that's what you do
now like in this extended bravy universe
that we find ourselves in that I want to
talk about um but I also think it is
Athletics and sport that teaches you um
the importance of patience and iteration
in terms of making a change because you
show up for practice every single day
and some days don't go so well back to
the rule of third some days go great and
a lot of them are just kind of in the
middle and you learn to just show up and
do the thing and do your best but detach
from the larger kind of outcomes of what
that might mean in the trajectory of
your career and you just do it and you
do it and you do it and you do it and
then that right-and
turn is a result of all of those you
know bazillion actions compounded that
starts to Arc a little bit more severely
than the kind of slow growth right and
that's what you learn for a career of
being an athlete but it's so applic
appable to every other aspect of your
life whether you want to make a change
or um you know alter your career or you
know step back and and entertain the
possibility of of finding a more
purposeful way of living like that's
really a potent and Powerful way to
approach it yeah I always like put
myself in the shoes or the chair of
someone who's like okay cool I've asked
myself this question I have this
abstract idea now what do I do with it
because as an athlete I prefer
instruction and I prefer like steps and
actions and so I feel like I can't leave
people with just laying there asking
questions and receiving abstract answers
like that feels like that doesn't
satisfy my need but it's a good first
step and I think that the next step is
to figure out what you actually do that
is something that I've drastically
shifted how I approach since being an
Olympian because leading up to the olymp
Olympics the steps there were very clear
and they were outlined by coaches right
as you said and they were tiered based
on what was most productive toward that
goal and now that the goal is less of a
tangible like I don't want to be an
Olympian anymore I want to have it those
certain feelings that I shared with you
or I want to share with the world and
they're not as rooted in a job or
tangible results so how do I pick my
actions now and how do I evolve that and
I think the way I do it now is really
different and I can share that too yeah
I'm interested in that because as an
athlete there's a certain number of
variables that you can control but there
aren't as many when compared to a
creative career path right like track
and field you train as hard as you can
you treat your body as as well as you
possibly can you do all the things and
then you show up on race day the track
is always the same distance it's
basically the same material give or take
a little bit um you can't control your
competitors or the weather you know
there's a number of things you can't
control but there's a lot that you can
control in a
creative uh
trajectory it's less a meritocracy
there's a lot of luck and happen stance
that comes into play it's less of a grit
equation like you can't grit your way to
success in a creative path in the way
that you can as an athlete Grit will
reward you like just keep writing or
just keep auditioning or whatever it is
but the outcomes are far less
predictable yeah and it's not just the
outcomes that are far less predictable
but the opportunities because in
athletics there's a pretty clear path to
your goal and there is variance in terms
of like weather conditions and those
things that you talked about but the
opportunity to qualify is very clear for
you right as you said and in the
creative world and in many many other
world in relationship World in all these
things there's the the Whiteboard or
Blackboard whatever you prefer what did
you have growing up uh what's your it
was pre- whiteboard that's how old I am
Blackboard yeah like chalkboards okay
chalkboard so just coaches yelling and
coaches yelling so on your chalkboard
would be the goals that you set for
yourself which like in an athletic world
uh it's much more like chalkboard driven
as far as what you want but there's also
a blank chalkboard and in the creative
worlds the blank chalkboard represents
what opportunities the world brings to
you and where where is there momentum in
the world or where could you fit in in a
collaborative way and to stick to the
the way of thinking that the athlete has
would be gold whiteboard you only pay
attention to one of those and you ignore
the entire blank chalkboard that might
bring you
opportunities and this was something
that I started thinking about there's a
mentor who was was on Saturday Night
Live and he said that that opportunity
came because somebody asked him if he
would ever think about auditioning for
that he never thought about it and that
represents that kind of blank black
chalkboard of stuff and so I think the
shift is knowing that like in in
evolving we can have like our goals that
we think we want and we can also be like
more open to like what is the world who
are these people what's going on how can
I like participate and um Monica who is
our shared physio shared with me some
really valuable um in like way of
thinking that helped me like Embrace
both of these chalkboards and that was
um when I was recovering from that same
surgery I was competing less because I
couldn't compete super hard for a while
and I was finding myself here in La
having a lot more fun so I was roller
skating a lot like at the Moonlight
rollerway is that like in Glendale or
something yeah yeah and it's awesome
because they have these like skate
nights and they're like you just feel
like you're entering another world and I
started going like every week and
inviting all these people that didn't
know each other and people would come or
they wouldn't it didn't really matter CU
I was going and I was going to have fun
and I talked to Monica because I
remember I was confused because I was
like what am I doing I never used to go
roller skating or do fun things like
this cuz they didn't feel productive to
my goals and I was asking her if I was
having a midlife crisis or if I was
practicing escapism from some bigger
thing that I was meant to be pursuing
right just because you're doing a normal
human being thing correct I mean I never
I didn't eat a s'more for like 10 years
when I chased the Olympic dream right I
I didn't do certain things because they
just weren't productive because they
weren't useful to that goal and I don't
really regret that I'll be honest with
you like the I really really committed
to that goal and I'm really happy that I
did but once I got it I guess I started
having fun right but that what's
interesting about that is how weirdly
indulgent it felt like uncomfortable for
you to just go out and do something for
no other reason than enjoyment it's so
uncomfortable I just went on my first
vacation I mean I think I've been on
vacation before but it felt like my
first vacation cuz I truly didn't do
work and it was terrifying because I
couldn't even get myself to do work and
then I thought I would never be able to
do work again the edge is gone it's just
it's but you I don't know if you need
the edge I think the the real question
is did you need the edge to get there in
the first place I know that's the real
question but so I asked Monica and I was
like what is this and she was like Alexi
I think you've only ever been thinking
about your life in terms of good for me
bad for me productive unproductive and
she said every cell in our body when
it's happy or safe it expands and moves
toward and that's like the feeling of
having a crush on someone or when
someone's like let's go out to Sushi and
you're like yes like that's a really
it's a known feeling that we have and
she said it's
cellular and it was the feeling I was
having roller skating and she said every
cell when it's unsafe it contracts and
moves away and
that's uh what you feel when somebody
puts food in front of you you're
allergic to or have had food poisoning
or something you know that feeling of
like I just won't eat that and she said
I want you to start thinking about your
life in terms of are these decisions
expansive or contractive to me or now I
think about it as do I have a crush on
this decision and once I started doing
that it made decisions a lot easier for
me and I started to actually evolve
without overthinking the decisions I was
making and doing things that like were
surprising to me which has been very
very useful I think that's a really
great frame to also grapple with the
question around like purpose and meaning
like when you cultivate that intuition
around the hell yes and you develop a
reflex to go towards those opportunities
there's something inside of you you know
you're you're you're saying yes to
something deep inside of you that is
perhaps under expressed right and by
moving towards that and finding a way to
give greater expression to whatever that
is I think is also creating a greater
alignment in your life between the
authentic version of you and however you
kind of show up for the world to
perceive you and I think the more you
you hone in on that alignment the better
position you're in to not only to your
point take advantage of opportunities
when they arise as a result of putting
yourself in those different situations
but also there's a there's a deeper
connection with the self that starts to
make space
for that purpose revealing itself right
like if you're just saying yes to the
things that your intuition is saying you
know I want that or I you know I need
this in my life um you're moving towards
that purpose that perhaps historically
has eluded you and it will reveal itself
in time but I think what happens is
people sit around in paralysis because
they don't have an answer to the
question of I have no purpose I'm just
going to wait until I get struck with a
lightning bolt of purpose before I make
any decisions but the purpose is
revealed in the actions yeah or they get
paralyzed by not understanding
why because sometimes you have a crush
on something and you don't know why and
sometimes something is contractive to
you or someone one and you don't know
why and I think that the getting away
from good for me bad for me productive
unproductive is really healthy because
it eliminates you obsessing over why you
know there could be a person that is
contracted to you that's a perfectly
good person they're wonderful whatever
they make you feel contracted that's
just information that your body is
giving you and you can choose to pay
attention to it or IGN it uh and it
really matters how you pay attention to
that information and I think the why has
been something that has really tormented
me it's so terrible to not understand
why an unexamined instinct can perhaps
Lead You astray and compel you to make
decisions that are not in fact your
interest but mascarade as being hell yes
because you haven't done enough kind of
internal work to understand understand
how you're impulsed and I think the more
you know internal investigation that you
do the more knowledgeable you become
about how and why you make those
decisions that lead you in the wrong
direction and the more connected you get
with the better version of yourself that
wants to make the healthier decision and
that healthier
decision often begins with discomfort
it's not it's not a function of a hell
yeah intuitive impulse as much as it is
is a contrary action that requires
repetition just like at the track until
you develop muscle memory and new neural
Pathways so it is more complicated than
that um than just you know the H the
hell yeah I think so that's my only kind
of note of caution on that but I do
think there's a lot to be said for the
blank whiteboard like you want your
goals and you want a path and you want
to know why you're doing what you're
doing every day and how that's moving
you in the direction of the person you
want to be or the things that you want
to achieve or the dreams that you want
to realize but you also have to hold
them Loosely enough so that you make
space for that blank page and what might
show up that could completely change
your course but ultimately lead you more
quickly like shortcut you towards that
dream or perhaps create a new dream that
you weren't even aware of that's better
that's probably most often what happens
right you think yeah I think usually we
end up somewhere surprising
yeah like sitting here talking to you
right now this was not on my
whiteboard wasn't on my chalkboard
either we didn't even know each other
[Music]
existed I want to talk about the
extended bravy
Universe okay that you've created uh
it's so interesting to kind of watch at
arms length and and kind of see what's
evolved since the last time we talked
not for nothing that podcast was really
popular I mean that clip of like the
rule of thirds where you just laid out
that rule I think on my Instagram it has
like 10 million views like people love
that went like crazy viral you came
out with this book bravy that did
phenomenally well and was just
universally embraced and now you have
this new book it's bravy for young
people right which is another move
towards this sort of cult-like status
that you've developed for yourself and I
say that half jokingly but I'm not alone
in saying that like multiple media
Outlets have said you've become this
like cult figure for the young
21-year-old girl who needs a hug and
needs to be told that it's going to be
okay so how do you like think about all
of
that
um I think I'm very lucky to have the
Braves and they're very lucky to have
me
because I
think
that there are vibrations in the world
like there are people who just vibrate
certain ways right and I've always from
the start been like someone who vibrates
at a very try hard level like Curious
try hard succeed well fall equally as
hard and there are people who feel like
that they feel curious they are lost
just like I am
meaning there's a vague ambition there
aren't always answers and so that's the
vibration generally it's like try
harders enough of a sense of humor but
also taking your goals
seriously um types and I didn't
exactly have a person who felt like that
to me growing up I don't I just
genuinely didn't and so I'm trying to
just do it so committedly because it is
so clearly who I am that there's a
bigger space for that kind of energy
and the word I'm grateful resonates but
I think more than anything I'm just so
happy to be in the game like I'm so
happy to be playing my game which is
just being myself and that that's
allowed in the world and that it has
allowed other people to play the game
similarly and that's like what it feels
like and so there's books there's the
company which was very much an act of
trying to be more independent as a
businesswoman and work with other women
that I really admire
but I just want
to be allowed to exist in the world and
have community and not hurt anybody and
see if that's allowed and it seems like
it is so far been allowed yeah I think
it is allowed I think what I see is this
Evolution from from somebody who was
perhaps perceived as inspirational like
an Olympian Greek 10,000 meter record
holder and then goes on to write direct
star in movies like that's so audacious
it's difficult for a lot of people to
kind of
access their own possibility on any kind
of trajectory that would look like that
but in the wake of of moving away from
professional running into
what's more kind of Fairly characterized
as a running Ambassador you're still
running and you're doing all these
events but you're doing it not for the
purpose of PRS or podiums but to be this
person who is demonstrating the joy and
the camaraderie and the community and
the possibility that comes with this
sport that you love so instead of um you
know being at the front of the pack
you're now you know behind behind that
pack with glitter on and you're running
around and you're high-fiving people and
you're smiling and you're laughing and
you're giving hugs to people and there's
something really potent and Powerful
about that that resonates with a lot of
people it is aspirational to run a
marathon and do it with a smile on your
face the entire time and look like
you're enjoying yourself and like giving
back as you're doing it that's a very
different relationship to sport look
running is a wonderful sport because it
can grow with you hopefully all sports
can grow with you in some way but
running specifically can obviously grow
with you if you let it if you let
yourself lead the pack of your own
running Journey instead of you know
staying behind yourself the
Practical you know reason why this has
all happened is simply because there's
only so much time in our lives and only
so much time in the day when I was
chasing the Rio Olympic dream the time
time that it took to train at that level
was everything right and it was the
North Star and I simply decided that I
wanted to reshuffle my cards in terms of
priorities but that running was still
important to me and I wondered could it
be possible to not retire in the way
that I saw my predecessors retiring
because there was this like thing where
people would retire and then they would
come out of retirement actually but
people like retire and I was like I
don't want to retire like I'm like not
even at my Peak age I don't know what
the future is and I actually think that
what is very freeing is deciding that
you actually don't know your future and
to not have to tell everybody something
that's so written in permanent marker
retirement is a pretty bold thing to say
about something you can do until you die
MH and so I didn't I chose not to retire
but I chose to just keep trying to
engage with the sport in a way that
felt expansive and it was a little scary
like when I danced in the New York City
marathon for the first time I actually
thought they were going to pull me off
the course like the race directors
because they didn't know I was going to
do it I didn't know I was going to do it
and they didn't they were thrilled and
very very supportive did you still was
that the year that you still lined up
with like all the pros and everything
because they no cuz rich I called the I
love the New York Road Runners team
because I called them and I was like
look I know my because my peers don't
all do this people don't always say hey
I might not be able to race my best
because they're
appearance fees there's money on the
line but I called them and I was like
listen I'm healthy but I'm not in shape
to like be competitive in this race it
would be dangerous to me cuz I'm only 8
to 10 months out from my surgery and
they were like we still want you on that
start line with the elites which is 30
minutes ahead of The Regular Pack how
many are in that group it's like 20
something people it's very small
relatively speaking and they were like
just run whatever Pace you want and I
was like that's crazy I'm going to be
running like you know alone because
there's a gap I'm not going to be with
these women and they were like we just
want you out there which was so nice but
so scary and so the glitter was actually
a decision I made I hired a makeup
artist he was so sweet and I put glitter
on my face to indicate to people that I
was okay that was literally it because
if you see someone jogging behind the
pack you think they are having a bad day
right cuz what's interesting about that
is the Elites all take off but there's
still a long time before the next flight
of people begins so you're behind them
and you're just in this no man's
completely in New York City alone New
York City these streets are wi with no
one no one in view in either direction
right it's terrifying you just put it
you just decide to put on a show well so
I put the Stars the glitter on first to
indicate that I wasn't injured to show a
playfulness right that was like a thing
to remind myself and to just show every
everyone clearly she's doing clearly
something else is going on as opposed to
oh no what's wrong what happened why is
she so far behind exactly so the glitter
was a was a communication device right
at first and then during the race what
overtook me was the sheer excitement of
a wide open road in New York City with
all these people around and nothing but
space and I was like I don't want want
to run in a straight line and so I just
remember seeing this intersection and I
was just like I just want to dance and
like just started like veering around
because it felt so like it felt like a
Broadway stage it felt like what
Broadway stars must feel like to have a
whole stage and all these people
watching and the and nobody's going to
jump up there and stop them from you
know it's like the school talent show
it's just like those like our cells only
feel feelings so like what I felt was
like theater talent show Vibes birthday
party School Dance 2 a.m. with your best
friends I just felt so many things that
were not roller skating in Glendale all
those things and then I was like I got
to do it so I did it and I think what
was so cool was I felt like really
connected to my mom who I lost when I
was very young but I know my mom was
theatrical and I know my dad is not and
I was like man I feel like I can't know
her but I something inside of me is like
from that side you can Channel her and
the performer Alexi comes out so I did
it and it was not illegal they didn't
pull you off the course no they didn't
pull me off the course and what was the
crowd reaction and the aftermath of of
doing that people cried because like
what I started to do was just make a lot
of eye contact with people and blow a
lot lot of kisses and like say I love
you I love you I love you to all these
people and in a way that wasn't it was
Earnest so it wasn't like cute you know
like you couldn't be cute and wave to
people or you can do it like uh you know
my business partner Christina about a
week before the marathon took me to this
Rave in La called Fleet mawood and it's
a Fleetwood Mac kind of
DJ Duo and there was this woman in the
front they have these dancers and she
was who I was in ired by because her
whole role was to like wear this gown
and basically blow kisses to people and
tell everyone she loved them and it felt
so good when she made eye contact with
me at the show and I remember with
Christina because I was expanded we
stayed out all night we danced we I
remember I had to sleepover with her and
it was like such a fun thing because
she's one of my first like adult
non-athletic best friends and making a
best friend in adulthood is really
unique so it was really special to me
and I remember channeling uh this woman
and trying to make people feel a
connection like I felt at that show and
so people were emotional about it and
you're right that they're used to seeing
people in pain and supporting them but
what it felt like was like a
genuine like disarming connection that
was entirely a product of everything
that it was was that like a a lightning
bulb moment for you like oh this is how
I can inhabit this world of running and
make my kind of imprint on it in a new
and interesting way that's really about
connection and not
performance yeah it was a light bulb
moment it
also made me feel
like the world is not done deciding what
all the occupations in the world are
because I have long felt really strange
about having such an athletic body and
not knowing what to do with it after
being an Olympian but knowing that it is
so capable and even though anybody can
dance through the streets of New York
City I know that it is also an athletic
feat to be able to dance through the
streets of a marathon for that long and
so it felt like an outermost expression
of my capabilities in a way that was
deeply satisfying to me as an athlete
also right yeah it's not easy to run a
marathon even if you're going slow but
to dance and do what you did the entire
way is its own form of athleticism yes
it is it's hard but it's fun yeah and
it's kind of inspired you know a
generation of of people who now run
races with glitter on and like there's a
whole thing around this now there's a
whole thing and and our my company is
designing a glitter and that's been
really fun it's our first our first
product is like we have these wonderful
like makeup scientist designing a glist
cosmetologist I think because the the
I've been having a challenge and
everyone's trying to figure out like
what glitter do I use and like how do we
get it to stay and not like burn through
our skin because the glue run you need
like yeah like sort of run approved glit
a glitter product yeah and something
that's bravy glitter bravy glitter wear
it to your you know you can wear it to a
rave as well if that's what you do and
you got chellan Flanigan to put a little
glitter on in that race too right chain
deserves a lot of credit from me for and
gratitude for everything she has done
for me cuz she has always been so
supportive of me even though she knows
we are so different and that day I
remember I had a a sweatband made for
her with little rhinestones on and she
was like so excited to wear them and she
was like where's my glitter and it was
so nice cuz like she didn't have to wear
the glitter and she didn't have to ask
and that she did was like an act of
someone you know a generation before me
in running saying without saying that
she supports me and that meant like a
lot to me and we need we need more of
that in every industry yeah that's so
cool I read somewhere about some other
advice that she gave you around pushing
through Pain by using the crowd or even
um looking at the birds that are flying
overhead when you're having a moment so
Dina Caster said that oh Dena did okay
apolog to Dina but it speaks to the
mentor thing it speaks to the mentor
thing what chellan told me was I think
you and I have talked about this either
on the podcast but probably on one of
our like bike runs was like just how
good chalain is at knowing what her goal
is and what she specifically needs to
get to her goal and to not let all the
noise of what she could do or could have
get in the way of her True North Star
and she's been really good with helping
me stay on track with that because with
any goal you have there's like a million
ways to get to it and not every
opportunity will actually get you there
I think we always play Shoots and
Ladders when we're chasing a goal and we
have to make sure we're continuing to
choose latter decisions and not ones
that are like shortcuts that eventually
take us down a slide backwards that gets
more and more difficult the closer you
get to the goal and the more successful
you become because the the opportunities
that are shoots always come beautifully
wrapped in very attractive packaging yes
they're so pretty so you want to say yes
to it and there sort of opportunities
that are celebratory of what got you to
where you're at but ultimately there're
sort of indulgent distractions that are
in the way of achieving the next thing
that you're trying to get to what do we
do there well it's the hell yeah thing
but also I think it's okay once in a
while to to do them but you have to do
them with self-awareness and you have
have to learn how to flex your no muscle
and and who was it I think it was Robin
arzon who says you have to protect your
yeses she has some great phrase around
like saying no to protect your yeses
yeah we have to slow down right like we
because the crush happens immediately
maybe really what we have to do is you
have your crush you have your like hell
yeah moment and then you have to like
sometimes when I'm talking to people I
stick my tongue behind my teeth so I
don't speak because I talk too quickly
and I say too much and it slows me down
and so sometimes maybe when I have a
crush the reality is that I have the
crush and then I have a pause where I
have a small conference with myself in
my head about what you are talking about
before making the decision uhhuh and you
metaphorically stick your tongue to the
back of your mouth no I really stick my
tongue you literally do that if you
stick your tongue behind your teeth you
can't
talk yeah okay helps me like not slows
you down yeah from being reactive well
and it's so weird cuz I was just
thinking about decisions and you know I
ran 100 miles right in this race I know
we were going to get to that but go
ahead well because it's about decision-
making because this will contradict what
we just said and this is I got to figure
this out because this is like two
different ways to think about things
there's like life decisions which you
need to take pause on but the advice I
got before the 100 mile from my amazing
friend in Pacer Mikey Mitchell was that
over the course of a 100 miles which I
was not prepared to run at all you need
to make a bajillion decisions and the
advice I got was that you need to make
them quickly and you need to not
overthink them and you need to just keep
moving and you need to keep making
decisions and it was the best advice
because over the course of 100 miles
you're making decision after decision
after decision do I walk do I run mashed
potatoes water shirt sports bra headlamp
music pass the girl Touch The Rock crawl
stand mhm sing cry and it was so helpful
to just keep making decisions and know
that you could just keep making
decisions and there weren't mistakes cuz
I can get really scared about is this
decision a mistake and he basically
freed me up to say I don't care if it's
a mistake just make the decision and so
I think something I'm trying to to
figure out in my life is what are the
instances where you should just keep
making decisions and not overthink them
and what are the moments when you're
meant to pause and put your tongue
behind your teeth and decide if that's
that's smart or not that's the ultimate
question isn't it if you can master that
I think you're in pretty good shape
we'll talk about that one next time when
we figure that out yeah yeah that's not
easy well let's talk about the 100 mile
I mean you didn't just do 100 miles you
did Leadville right so we're talking 100
miles at like what is it like 9,000 ft
or some insane altitude starts at 105
105 no air and a very long distance to
go and very little training leading up
to it I mean you did do how long before
did you do the 100K That was supposed to
be a 50k until the night before and you
decided without having trained for it
that you were going to run 100K
January and Leadville was
in how many months later it was uh
September okay mid- September yeah yeah
yeah you were running but you didn't
train to run 100 miles at 10,000 ft
no I actually took like at least five
weeks off because I went to my cousin's
wedding and I wore these platform shoes
and my calf got irritated because you
shouldn't you shouldn't do that but I
think what was so cool was I was
genuinely curious what it would be like
to run a race where I was you know 40
30%
fit and 100% recovered and healthy so
during that time off when my calf was
just like being a brat I really buckled
down on like sleep bone broth just the
things that make me feel whole again and
I was so recovered I had like so much
like I don't know I felt like like the
Tin Man full of oil or like just totally
totally recovered and totally unfit and
I was curious about that because you
don't get to do that when you're chasing
an Olympic dream you must ride the edge
of fitness and injury at all times in a
way that is like carefully governed by
your coach and hopefully executed
perfectly it was really cool to rely on
emotional maturity years of mileage and
optimism from every cell that it had
like lots and lots of Reserve inside and
my friends my friends were my crew so it
was like super fun so walk me through it
there must have been some hard moments
though so I went in like believing I
could finish and deciding I would finish
it and not knowing exactly what it would
feel like or look like and I think I
started out I just didn't want to get
pulled off the course so what happens in
Leadville and it's it's very known for
this is that at every aid station you
will get pulled if you don't hit a
certain time so I was just like I hope
I'm not under the time or over the time
and I thought I like was close because
like there was a girl near me that was
like I don't want to get pulled and I
was like are we close are they gonna
like hook us and and we weren't close
because I came into mile 40 I was in
fifth place I think and then a thing
inside of me that I cannot control came
into play which is I was like I want to
be
racing um I'm in
fifth okay yeah but I yeah careful so I
I think I this is just a nerdy athletic
thing but I just I took way too many
salt pills I don't know I I thought they
were electrolytes I think and I just way
dehydrated myself so I wasn't prepared I
wasn't having like proper fueling I was
like eating whatever I felt like so I
was very very dehydrated to the point
where I was like drinking out of creeks
and like just sitting on the side trying
to get water and I needed to walk the
last 40
miles that was a decision that
felt shameful at first cuz I think you
know when you come from a background of
not walking you don't think you should
walk but I guess to finish a race like
that is an accomplishment uh so my first
half was like much faster than my second
half and it was a really beautiful
experience to be given the opportunity
to just be in nature I mean I'm curious
about how you feel about this but I feel
like you and I are so busy and so what
ultr running provides is like a space to
be in nature for a really long time
feeling like this is exactly where you
belong there's space to explore within
it you can do it however you want and
this is where you belong and I think I
felt most happy in life when I'm like
exactly where I belong which happens in
ultr running cuz you're there for long
enough that you get to really relax into
it and it happens for me on movie sets
cuz you're definitely where you belong
when you're on a movie set and it's
really hard to like get that anywhere
else in life for me even running
daytoday you know you get an hour and a
half you don't get like 24 hours to be
in nature so really it felt like a gift
that's really beautiful and I think on
top of that you know it's a different
type of athlete and in and competitive
environment from what you're used to as
somebody who's been running around
tracks forever and running on roads to
go to the trail and tap into that
subculture which has a certain
kind of aee decor and and Community kind
of vibe to it that not that road races
in track don't have that but it's a
different kind of texture people are not
competitive like moment to moment in
Ultras like you see someone on the side
of the road you will help them you will
give them snacks people are taping each
other up it's like I've said this but
you feel like you're in another time
period because it's just survival and
moving and it's so awesome it's like a I
hope everybody experiences it if they
can what else was different about it
coming from your version of running your
background what was different about
it uh you're not supposed a red line
like you're really supposed to okay
what's really different about it is you
are not supposed to run in packs or it
doesn't serve you to run in a pack in
ultra running for me you have to listen
to your body and answer to what it needs
moment to moment moment and not question
it so you might run up a hill but walk
down and that's what you genuinely need
so it's much more answering to what you
need instead of ignoring what you need
which in in Track Running you ignore
pain because it is only temporary and
you can push through that and I think in
ultr running you familiarize yourself
with it and you either befriend it and
walk with it or you heed to it and give
it what it needs did it leave you
wanting to do more in that world it did
look I'm curious as to what I could do
in ultra running if I trained yeah I
don't know if I will but I think if I if
I trained like I would rip I think I
could do quite well it's another
decision tree of thinking about
protecting your yeses and what you say
no to right when you have the
opportunity like should you make that
decision to invest yourself in that that
opens up a whole like life of you know
like training and Etc and then you have
this creative life over here that seems
to be taking precedent in terms of like
where your your heart really is at the
moment and you can't go full bore into
both at the same time right so you have
to make these compromises and an
investment in your athleticism comes
perhaps as a debit to your creative
aspirations probably but I think there's
a world where they can go exist I think
we'll we'll see but in the creative
world something that has been helpful is
just embracing that I'm an athlete and
not being so demure and not saying that
I don't do it anymore I think I used to
have a narrative that I don't do it
anymore and now I've realize I actually
don't have to do that I can run every
day and be in Hollywood sure people do
it I understand training at that level
it it might take tradeoffs but I'm
curious I I don't know I don't know how
possible what you just said what that
balance I don't know it would be cool if
you were like all right there's a race
you know maybe it's a year and a half
from now I'm going to set a long-term
goal to to like approach that from a
performance perspective while also
chasing all these other creative dreams
at the same time because the creative
world is it's not a nine-o-five job if
you're making a movie it's all consuming
but in the kind of day-to-day aspect of
you know writing and taking meetings Etc
there's plenty of room for you to train
much as you want I think there is and
living here we live in a place that has
the trails we need and the access to the
creative stuff we need so I'm curious in
navigating it I we'll see you know I
don't
know the other thing you've been doing
with your running I want to get to the
creative stuff but while we're on the
running is working with paralympians so
talk a little bit about how you got
interested in that and what that whole
world is like I I know very little about
all of that it's super super cool
because so I've been guiding for
visually impaired athletes and one in
particular Lisa who I met because she
she she hadn't had many female guides I
think one other it's hard for a fast
blind female to find a female guide
because they the guide needs to be
faster than them in a way and needs to
be in a place to give that time
and I was curious because I I'd always
wanted to like run the Boston Marathon
but I did not want to compete in it and
she wanted to win and guiding her has
been a really nice expression of like a
competitive team oriented person inside
of me that didn't know where to like
Express that cuz I love teams and I love
competing and so guiding you are like
first of all it's very technical like
you have to learn how this person works
and how to get them what they need get
them where they need uh and that's a joy
and it's also a challenge so you learn
this technical stuff and then when the
the race happens you are kind of like
their loving team captain cuz you're not
their coach and you're not passive you
will have an impact and I think that's
the thing that people need to realize if
they want to guide is that you will
never have a neutral effect on the
athlete you will either help them or you
will limit them and so you need to like
learn how to be helpful rather than
limiting but it's been fun and like I
have a whole community of friends I
think I'm going to be guiding like some
non visually impaired but you can also
like assist ambulatory athletes in
certain races and what's fun about it is
that I think that I know a thing or two
about competing and I like applying it
to somebody else's success mhm it's so
interesting I mean just the idea of
being visually impaired and like running
as hard as you can is like wild when you
think about it yeah so their life really
is in your hands totally you have a lot
of responsibility when you're doing that
which I would imagine is kind of
stressful especially when they're trying
to win or be competitive yeah and they
can be they can have their moments yeah
like Lisa I love her she would not deny
that she has her moments during races
but every teammate has their moment
right like I was on the Oregon team we
were winning national titles I had
teammates getting Snappy with me but
like as a team captain you just know
exactly how to find that balance and how
to get them to their goal because only
you know what the watch says only you
know what hill is ahead and it's kind of
like a game of like how to get them to
perform their best and you're you're an
audio book right like so to get her to
you know you mentioned the birds
overhead the crowds she can't see any of
that so I get to be an audiobook and
kind of filter the world through what I
think will be interesting to her and
make her feel less pain wow and that's
fun you're like hot guy running by and
she's like hot guy like hot guy for me
hot guy for you I'm like that one's for
you you know and it's like it's super
fun to like have that relationship with
somebody so you're going to continue
doing this I mean where does that where
can that take you I mean it can take you
to to guiding in the parall Olympics
which is like a thing that that I would
love to do someday it can take you to
just continuing to like do these
circuits and and help other people I did
a camp at the Olympic Training Center in
Colorado Springs right before Leadville
and so you trained a little I trained
little yeah yeah oh I acclimated a bit
that was helpful I'm still you know I'm
still smart right you got train and then
you're like well I was when I was at the
train the Olympic Training Center before
lville yeah oh I acclimated okay to be
clear
but what was interesting was it was a
guide Camp so there were not visually
impaired athletes for most of the camp
and we had to play the role of being
blind often and so we blind you know I I
was blindfolded and that was really
interesting too because you can't always
understand what somebody needs until you
understand what you would need in that
situation so communication especially
like a level of trust I can't imagine
it's got to be scary put a blindfold on
and just run as hard as you can it's all
about trust like it is all about trust
and communication and confidence even if
you don't you aren't sure you must be
confident as a guide I think the thing
that people don't always understand is
like par athletes are super competitive
like and they are normal people and
that's what's been fun also is like
people need to spend more time in that
Community people need to understand that
these people are competitive hilarious
smart multifaceted people people that
have a disability but they they also
have goals needs fears desires of course
right what an interesting cool thing
it's super fun the more I think about it
the more like wild it is but of course
visually impaired people are not the
only people that you Pace what were the
uh highs and lows of of pacing Diplo at
the LA Marathon how did that happen that
was fun well well the way it happened
was he was running the race he was going
to be running the race I was going to be
running the race with a a partner choros
who is a sponsor of the race you know
I'll be honest with you I I've always
tried to like find an orientation with
races that makes me feel like I
understand what I'm doing and so there
was an opportunity to like run with him
because he didn't have somebody
necessarily to run the whole race with
he'd never run a marathon and
he's very athletic and I was so
impressed by his ability to stay on his
own team like the the guy had never R
more than a half marathon I think and he
was just so positive he was so positive
and I was like oh this is a human who
may have very little experience in
marathoning but who surely has had
certain things that he has either
learned or was born with to do what he
has done in his career and it was
fascinating to spend time with somebody
you know in an unfamiliar territory for
them but see qualities of them come out
that must serve them in the rest of
their life well certainly he's athletic
I think he just did the Malibu Triathlon
the other weekend but most famously he's
the guy who made it out of Burning Man I
know I know I know so all that Marathon
all that training and that like mental
resilience uh clearly came into play
with him trudging through the mud and
getting out of there yeah when everyone
else was stuck right okay so one thing
that happened during the race that I
think that speaks to this is that I
noticed he wasn't taking in like a lot
of food or fuel right and I was like he
probably doesn't train with gels and
things like that and I as his like
person who wanted to help him get
through I was like he should probably
eat something right I wasn't going to
like grab a goo and be like eat this
mysterious food that you don't know
because that can also get in someone's
head so like part of being like a good
teammate to upset his stomach if he's
not used to that exactly and so part of
being a good teammate to someone is
understanding how to help them without
making them feel like they're missing
something or self-conscious right and so
I asked him if he could imagine eating
something and he was like yeah I think I
could eat something and I was like okay
what looks good and he gravitated
towards orange slices and that was great
so we just ate or and so I ate oranges
and I think that that that that points
to one of those specific things about
like guiding or pacing that is helpful
is just to like read the room and try to
get them to the goal of like nourishment
without trying to force it on them in
the way that you think is best but in
the way that might work for them right
yeah yeah yeah I like that encouraging
rather than kind of inferring that
they're doing it wrong yeah like ad that
becomes like a mind virus yeah you want
to like it's all posit it's all good and
as long as they're eating some you know
it's like who cares if it's an orange or
some you know like as long as they're
eating something and they feel they
believe in it it's all about the mental
stuff right so he was on his own team I
wasn't going to I wanted to keep him on
his own team and we had fun like he has
a sense of humor you get to know someone
over the course of a marathon uh and
we've we've run since and he really
likes running that's cool that's cool I
also read that you have a race named
after you now in San Francisco is that
true that's true it's a 10K how did that
happen well is it like the bravy 10K or
is it the Alexi papis 10K we have both
you do they're two different ones yes
you have two races named after you there
are two and one of them is the Alexi
papus well it's the San Francisco
marathon Alexi papus 10K so it's with
the San Francisco marathon in the summer
uh which is very fun because there are
so few marathons that you can run in the
summer so I like that that exists and
then the Berkeley half marathon has the
bravy 10K and that's around Thanksgiving
so it's coming up and that one I'm
really excited about because I was born
in Berkeley and there's an alliteration
with bravy that naturally lends itself
to fun whatever have you that's that's
very cool have you ever done you must
have have you done the Beta Breakers
race cuz that's like that has like bravy
written that's like the original bravy
race costumes are mandatory there's like
floats people carrying floats and it's
just a parade like I did do it I did do
it um because it ends at the beach right
and you go over the big hill yes I went
over the big hill I joged it that was a
race before I figured out how to like
jog in with my own it was like normal
people no like how to like Orient in the
run like I think I I just I remember
feeling very lost in that race because I
was like running it but I wasn't
competing it was in this in between time
but before I had figured out like who I
was in the after competitive life m
that's probably why I probably blacked
it out I feel like you could be a flag
bearer in that race though you know it's
like right up your I don't know it's
basically like your ethos RIT large
where everybody is like flamboyantly
dressed and like it's a whole it's a
parade basically yeah yeah you should
definitely do that I'll do it again and
then this time I'll remember all right
what is going on with you creatively you
directed a movie with Rizza I can say
that premiered because it premieres in
like a week or two oh it does yeah so
the movie premieres in Austin but it was
um South by Southwest no it's the Austin
Film Festival which is like a fun like
well attended festival and it has
distribution with Utopia who did like
Shiva baby and that sort of that's legit
yeah yeah so that'll come out in
2024 that's next year theatrical release
probably yeah I think it'll do its thing
and that's you know what's fun is like
you I don't know if you feel this way
I'm trying to think about your life
maybe books but like sometimes you make
things and then you kind of have to you
kind of put them on dormant in your mind
when they're like finding their way and
then they come to life again like a
flower MH and it's fun it's like a wild
flower that you forgot about right
because there's so much time that takes
place in between when you've completed
it and when the world actually gets
introduced to it and when you can do
anything about it like it's kind of like
it had there's like times when you can't
you know creative arts are like playing
tennis you just like keep hitting the
ball into the other court and sometimes
it's on the the other side of the court
for a long time but um my real sites
creatively are set on uh navigating my
way into the television world so um I
have before the writer strike I was
pitching big television shows that were
either like we just didn't hear back
from certain places or we were about to
pitch uh and then we couldn't and so now
uh we are back in it and it is like
super exciting because television feels
much more like an athletic career
translated into the Arts in that movies
are so like like and I love movies I
want to keep making movies but
television feels more
like it takes a long time to put
together but there's like a team there
are seasons there are episodes which are
like sports games so that's a goal um
that is cool and are these projects that
you're all Co you're co-writing with
somebody or you're writing yourself so
I'm being more independent in my
creative life and I have collaborators
for all these projects they're all
different but they all came to me
because of my athletic career and I'm
really grateful that I seem to be like
the runner the athlete in Hollywood and
it's it's fun because I can speak to it
but no project has the same
collaborators and that's new for me to
not be working with Jeremy on right
everything or anything it's scary but
it's like
empowering so interesting we move so
quickly past the movie you didn't even
say what the movie is or what it's about
yeah the movie that stars the Rizza is
called not an artist and I remember I
ran into on the trail and the one
weekend we got to go home from we shot
it in Big Bear and we shot it during Co
at a it was a while ago it was a while
ago and it was a summer we shot it at a
summer camp for diabetic children and it
was really awesome because they didn't
have they weren't able to like
do anything with this camp and it like
helped I think it helped keep the camp
going but we also got to shoot at a
summer camp uh and it's about an artist
in Residency program that the rizza's
character started for artists who have
claimed that they're artists but have
yet to create any meaningful work and
they get one month to create the project
they apply with or they have vowed to
quit the Arts forever so it's a comedy
but it's really just like kind of
calling people out a little bit
playfully for when people say they're an
artist or they say they're an athlete or
they say they it's like then go chase
and do the thing like go make something
if you say you want to be doing that
thing and it's a fun movie that's cool
and it's also the first project that
isn't about Athletics that you've done
yeah which is so that's a like a
maturation to kind of depart from the
world that you know so well and do
something different yeah it's it's very
different and I learned a lot doing it I
learned that I want to wear fewer hats
moving forward cuz like to be everything
for an artistic project isn't as
effective as like doing one thing well
and I want that to be an artistic
Evolution too is
to be more focused and have better
teammates who do what they do very well
so that I can do something better one of
the challenges that I always
have is when I wake up in the morning
I'm a morning person I do my best work
in the morning it's my best time to
train but it's also the best time for me
to write where I'm freshest and I'm
always feeling the tension between these
two things like I can go out and run and
you know move towards my fitness goals
or I can write and hopefully move
towards creative goals that have more
permanent to them like CU once you've
written it it's like it's there forever
whereas your Fitness you know kind of is
fleeting and these things always seem to
be at odds with each other or or
fighting with each other for attention
and and I'm never sure that I've been
able to strike the appropriate kind of
balance that I can adhere to over long
periods of time is that something that
you contend with yes like the exact same
thing but I think that
it's probably important to
defer to the Arts first because with
running like if you're okay with the
like 10 to
15% margin of error with like training
not being perfect your training is
always like a reflection of effort right
so if at the end of the day you don't
feel your best but you've like scheduled
your run your cells are going to still
like get the effort in whereas I feel
like with the writing and the creative
work you might not
generate like do you know what I mean
like I it's okay if the if you if you
push the run and do it later and it's
not as good and you don't feel as good
or whatever
that's fine because you really need to
protect the writing because it's
fleeting and less predictable well and I
think you're running you can still get
better even if it doesn't feel as good
it just will be a different set of
challenges right like running Fitness is
just stress on the body so if the stress
is that you're more tired I don't think
you get not not you're more tired but
you're like your willpower is lower I
don't know I mean so for you the
creativity is first like in the day in
the life of Alexi how does it play out
how it really plays out is I will try
and schedule my runs with people because
that is the most likely thing to get me
to do the run and and sometimes that
means they in the morning sometimes it
means they in the afternoon but a
scheduled like meeting time with
somebody gets me so much farther than I
will call it practice with myself so
there's like a scheduled time and then I
do my best writing in the morning as
well like I'm definitely not a late
night
person so that's it I mean I just I use
my Google Calendar I feel like this
isn't a very interesting answer because
it's just like a a scheduling discipline
thing yeah people are obsessed with
morning routines okay somebody who has
big goals and has achieved a lot of
things I think it's interesting to kind
of learn about how you structure your
day so that you're making sure that
you're taking care of the things that
you need to take care of and you're
moving in the direction that you want to
be moving in well I'll tell you in the
last few days I've been very jetlagged
and waking up really really early like
against my will and it's been amazing so
like first I was waking up at like 2:30
and I I know there's like the 500 a.m.
book and I'm starting to think I should
read it because I feel so much less
stressed honestly when I go abroad I
feel so much less stressed because I
know that during my waking hours
everyone in most of my life is asleep
and so I feel calmer and I think when I
wake up way
earlier it I feel way less stressed so
you can wake up get your stuff set up
without feeling like you're already
behind and that's probably more
important than like when am I going to
write when am I going to run it's like
how am I going to get my head straight
before the world is like bombarding
me yeah when nothing else is competing
for your time and attention yeah and you
feel like it's the same thing with the
ultr running it's like how do you create
more time in your life when you feel
like you are where you belong and you
don't have the anxiety of being pulled
everywhere I think time management in
Los Angeles particularly with the things
that that you're doing
becomes really important because of the
distances you know like if you're going
to have a meeting or a lunch with
someone oh yeah there's so much driving
involved it's not like hey let's meet
for coffee that could be a 4-Hour Affair
depending upon where you live and where
the other person lives and where you
decide to meet um so you have to be
really judicious and again it goes back
to you know being being careful about
what you say yes to and this is a town
of meetings right where everybody wants
have lots of meetings um but I know
where you live and those meetings
typically take place about an hour drive
from here so you're looking at you know
three hours minimum just to meet with
someone I meet with people a lot less
than I used to and it's actually been
okay and I also am not perfect about
getting back to people and that's also
been okay because if someone really
needs something from you they will tell
you that and I think think I've become
less like the first email respondent
immediate Than I Used to Be and that's
also helped a lot like just to be like
85% excellent at everything is is
honestly like okay I don't mean your
work I mean you're like functioning
right was that difficult for you as as
an Olympian who's used to striving for
perfection in all things to acclimate to
it was difficult as a person who thought
that if I messed anything up or one
thing fell through the cracks that my
whole life would end and that you're a
bad person yeah or that I wouldn't get
that chance again I don't know if that
comes from like the Olympian I've really
like struggled with thinking that I can
like make any mistake and that it will
be
okay talk more about that
well it's something I noticed in college
when I like wouldn't get something like
if I applied for some thing and I didn't
get it I would think that I would never
get an opportunity like that again and I
started noticing that I was very like
thinking that life was a connect the
dots but if you missed a rung on the
ladder you would fall and not that there
was
another rock to grab and instead of just
one
knob and sports should have taught me
otherwise actually because you lose a
lot of games and that doesn't mean
you're going to lose the season MH but
I'm always like is this some childhood
like who knows I don't know why but the
only way to grow out of it is to see
yourself mess up or miss an email
response or not get something and keep
going and see if it turns out okay okay
and then to pause and say hey look this
turned out okay so now I'm someone who
can not get everything and still be okay
and so I'm trying to take more moments
in my life where I question the rules
I've made for
myself and recalibrate and have a proper
update on my system to reflect what is
true and not what is scary yeah I think
that's a interest reflection of maturity
like I think it it speaks to kind of
where you're at in your you know mental
health Evolution which has been such a
big part of everything that you do and
who you are and what you write about and
talk about that feels very grown up in a
good way so I guess I'm curious like
where where are you now as somebody who
who is you know kind of a public facing
voice around mental health issues like
where are you right now with your mental
health and what are the challenges that
you're still facing or that come
up I am always monitoring my nervous
system CU I think that my Depression
started with depletion is my
understanding of it now and looking back
there were signs like physical signs on
my body that I was like depleted and
ignored those so physically and
otherwise well definitely mentally but
as a as a athlete I'm always looking for
something very specific and so I was I
was told that we have the most nerves on
our like in our face hands stomach and
so I was told by physio first I was told
to think back to when I was depressed
like really bad what happened like in
the weeks before and he said did you
remember anything on your face and I
remember I had canker sours in my mouth
and that's not normal for me and he he
told me that you have the most nerves in
your face your hands and your gut and
your stomach and that if I
notice something off about that I should
pause because your nervous system is
your first line of depletion and that
that will then compound and that can
lead to a depression like I had a
situational depression so to pause and
so now like if I have like an eye twitch
or a a pimple because that is not always
normal for me or like a splotch on my
face I'll slow down and it's nice to
have a physical sign to be like I got to
take a day off cuz I have this thing so
that's like specific but then on a
bigger
level I'm I'm in like a really intense
like therapy thing with my like I found
a car in La that's different than who I
worked with on my post Olympic
depression because you need to work with
someone in person and with someone in
Oregon and I'm doing istdp which is
intensive short-term psychodynamic
therapy whoa yeah it's intense explain
so there are longer sessions and
I I think the core of it is like helping
people maybe this is reductive but I
think it helps people access like their
anger
essentially and it's long sessions
because often times what is masking
anger is confusion and what I have been
learning about myself is that I have a
lot of confusing thoughts or I have
thoughts and feelings that confuse me
and they cause me as you talked about
earlier to make decisions that aren't
good for me or to think I should make a
decision that I don't make that wouldn't
have been good for me and so the therapy
is like I mean the therapist is kind of
like hard on me it's not the that she's
like provoking me but I think she is
trying to like
delayer impulses of mine and it takes a
while because usually there's like your
feeling and then there's what you think
the feeling is and then there's actually
the real feeling and then there's what
you know there's like all those layers
yeah yeah and I've needed to to do that
work because I've put myself in really
compromising situations in my personal
life and I need to understand how to
make my intellect and my feelings align
cuz they often are at odds where I know
something intellectually but I don't
feel it and so I have in my life like
borrowed other people's feelings to help
me for example like I'll know
intellectually I'm in a situation that
isn't healthy and I'll express it to a
friend and they'll have the anger or the
feelings but I won't feel anything I
will understand I should feel this but I
won't feel
it so that's kind of like what this work
is helping with
and one interesting exercise I've had to
do which I can tell you cuz it's so cool
well like so one of the confusing
thoughts just to give you an example is
like she discovered that when I cry I
cry when I'm mad not when I'm sad and
that was something that was confusing me
because I was going through a period of
time I was crying a lot and I didn't
know why I was crying and I thought it
meant I was not doing good things with
my life and I should go backwards but it
was from anger and that was because as a
child it was not safe to be angry around
my mom so I cried and that was safe to
do the exercise I was going to tell you
about was I basically was diagnosed I
was laugh cuz I'm uncomfortable but with
like um PTSD that's a big word to use
but in my instance it was about not
being able to feel pain so I was just
telling my friend about this this
morning but when you like hear a lot of
loud music sometimes you can't hear as
well afterwards because your body adapts
and you don't have as great of hearing
and I think for me I saw a lot of like
unseeable things as a kid so I probably
cannot feel pain like normal people can
or couldn't um because it was not useful
for me to feel pain so that might
explain why I ran so well or like when
people are like Mad at me historically I
don't react like a like I perceive
normal people would I can just handle it
so the exercise I was given was so
simple and so cool which was just to um
I'm not a great artist like a fine
artist so this works for people who are
not fine artists to draw my feelings
with the opposite hand so I'm
left-handed so I drew with my light
right hand my emotions so sadness
happiness anything anger and it's not
about what you're drawing it's the act
of drawing opens up your feelings
channels it doesn't matter what you draw
and because I'm not a great artist it's
not an intellectual side of my brain
it's a feeling side and it really worked
and I started to feel so so when you're
drawing that emotion it conjures the
emotion the act of trying to
characterize it it's more like lifting
weights where it opens up Pathways to be
able to feel the emotions it might
conjure the emotion but it also like
will open the pathways more permanently
so that you can feel again I think it's
like lifting weight it's like it's an
exercise that you don't have to like
think about it while you're doing it
just by doing it you will create that
and so I started to feel and that was
really hard cuz then I was feeling
things from the past that I never felt
and that was really uncomfortable cuz
then you're like feeling all this stuff
that you didn't feel which maybe helped
you in some ways and limited you in
others and so my mental health journey
is like something that I'm definitely
not like sharing a ton about because I
don't I'm just like I'm in it and the
the newest thing that I'm trying to do
is be more
okay like with myself so
like just trying to like spend more time
alone weirdly
and there's just so much so I go I see
her a lot and she's trying to help me be
less confused is that exercise part of
how you discovered that tears were
associated with anger and not
sadness no she noticed that so she's a
very good doctor and in our sessions she
would talk to me about things and I
would cry and she would ask me like what
are you feeling right now and she would
help me get to the point where it was
like no I'm actually angry and what's
heartbreaking sometimes for people or
for me I should just speak for myself
about anger is that you can be really
angry at something and still understand
it at the same time so like my dad not
telling me how my mom died and how he
raised us I love him but there were
things he left out
emotionally that I understand so much
now I wrote a whole book as like almost
a love letter to him but there's also
some anger about like
that would have helped like it would
have helped to talk about that stuff
then so that's the kind of anger where
it's like they Co they they exist with
understanding but if you don't ever feel
it I guess maybe it just stays inside of
you she talks about like
anxiety and it helps me cuz she says
like when we feel anxiety cuz we all
feel it and it's supposed to actually
like save our life if like a car is
coming or something we're supposed to
ask two questions is is this a real
threat or not so a real threat is is
there a bear about to eat me and if it's
not a real threat then she says that
it's an unfelt feeling and that those
are the feelings that you work on in
therapy and the more unfelt feelings you
have the more debilitating your anxiety
might be when there's not an actual real
threat that's so
cool um it's not
surprising that you you know as a young
person being exposed to you know certain
things that were traumatic that you
would develop this defense mechanism of
compartmentalizing you know your your
anger or your whatever other emotions
come up in association with that but
then to realize much older how much
you've repressed those and how you've
used it as a tool to Excel and then rely
upon it almost you know to make your way
in the world only to discover that it
has diminishing returns right like
ultimately you will be a more whole
capable person if you can heal all of
this and broaden your kind of emotional
Spectrum to manage stuff right but to
let go of this thing like well it's
great that I don't feel pain because I
can just like power forward and Crush
right and very frightening to say well
what happens if I decompartmentalization
that might debilitate me right without
having the right tools to manage it and
find healthier strategies for how to
process all of those confusing emotions
yeah and it might kind of break your
heart because you might realize that
some circumstance you were in that made
you angry was
unacceptable and I think why people
repeat
patterns that for example expressions of
love that maybe are not really loving
why to accept that they're not
acceptable or you're angry about them is
to say that it may not have been love in
the first place but to repeat it is to
live under the guise that it was always
love and that is more comfortable for us
to think it was love then it's love now
and the harder growth is to say that
wasn't how I wanted to be loved then for
example
and to take a different path is to feel
heartbroken that that might not have
been what you really thought it was yeah
so it's like a it's wild to be like cuz
you functioned in like a reality maybe
that wasn't the truth or something or
wasn't good enough I don't know how to
describe it but it's like
whoa if you were to go full bore back
into running with
everything you know more way more down
the line and on the other side of like
this mental health experience that
you've been having for many years um do
you feel like you would be much better
equipped to like be like a champion
athlete knowing what you know about
yourself and the the parts that you've
addressed and healed yes like
100% like I have just such a little
curiosity of like if I had Fitness which
is just something you go out and and you
you earn what I could do is like it is
really fun to think about because your
emotional maturity is very very
meaningful yeah yeah yeah yeah if you
were interested in channeling that in
the ultra Trail world like you can
compete well beyond your years right now
right like there's a lot of potential
there should you choose to accept it
even in the marathon I mean like people
peak in the marathon at like mid-30s or
right it's like so I'm not there yet
there's a time thing but I do think in
Ultra there could be a a window of you
know there could be something to explore
there and it's it's wild when you
compete I don't know if you feel this
way but like you can sense maturity and
immaturity in other people I mean okay
my favorite thing about competing is
when you're so fit that you can play you
can compete on like a mental level
because the body is not the limiting
factor it's like the mind and it's
playing with people and like in a in a
perfectly wholesome athletic way that is
the most fun thing what are your mental
Warfare tactics well when you're really
fit and you're you're competing against
people what you do is you assess their
strengths and their weaknesses in the
beginning of the race and you have your
plan that you come up with your coach or
whatever but you also are assessing your
competitors and understanding like what
are their strengths and their weaknesses
so let's just say there's a girl who's
really good at uphill another girl is
really good at downhill classic you can
sense confidence because you're smart
emotional being then later in the
race like so you you hang back cuz
you're you're assessing you're figuring
it out and you don't want them to know
how how strong you are and then later in
the race you start to play with them
where like and you study the course so
you know it there was this one race
where there was an uphill a downhill and
an uphill and a downhill finish and
there were two girls it was this one was
good at uphill one was good at downhill
and I let them bicker with each other
the entire race we weeded out everybody
else there was a whole pack everyone
else's gone it's just us three and I
knew there's an uphill girl and the
downhill girl girl and on the second to
last uphill I press from behind but let
the girl who's good at uphill ultimately
win that uphill so she thinks she
is the dominant uphill Runner okay and
then on the penultimate downhill I press
the downhill girl so I'm on her and I
let her feel that she's won that
downhill and then on the final
uphill just pass that uphill girl and
just break her she's out the back and
then the final downhill just jump the
downhill girl because she thinks she's
got it right you give them a false sense
of confidence yeah so but you can't you
can't play like that unless you're fit
right and you're fit you can play like
and that's really fun and that's where
like I kind of get sad about the Olympic
standards because they're so fast now
that like racing it's just a time trial
it's like all these scared people who
want to run these times but like real
running is like racing and maybe that's
why ultra running is so attractive to me
because if I were fit enough to do it
it's not about time and there's a lot of
ability to play like that sure but the
the other thing yeah has nothing to do
with time but it also has much less to
do with what other people are doing if
you're running 100 miles it's really not
about who's strong on the uphills and
who's strong on the downhills it's
really just between you and you that's
true I mean there's I I assume at the
highest level there's more right if
you're you're in the top 0 one% maybe
that's different but for everybody else
well you're not spending as much time
with people right like in these track
races and these road races you can hear
people's thoughts you are so close to
them you can just hear everything and so
you're reading you're playing and it's
so fun but you don't deploy that
verbally like you're not saying no but
it's all in anything to them well and
this is where like acting and running
are not that different because you
really are like there's a lot of theater
in running when you're at that level and
it's like so fun like it it is really
really fun when your body and I wish it
for everybody that everybody body has a
time in their life where they feel their
body is super capable um and you're not
fighting your own body you're like able
to like use it as this like tool and I
know that that's a very rare place to
get to yeah and the cost of that comes
at you know the price of some of the
other goals that you're pursuing yeah
you have to we you have to weigh like
how much do you really want to feel like
that again in a race I felt it yeah I
felt it yeah you you have but to feel it
again well but there's the Curiosity of
what would the mental maturity like what
would your what else could you bring to
it it's I'm curious It's not a need and
it never it never felt like too
desperate and I think it's really really
important for people to never need the
goals that they want more than they want
to keep playing curiosity is better than
need that's all oh that's interesting
explain that a little bit more I think
to be driven by curiosity is like to be
running toward and not running away from
from and it's
buoyant and it has dynamicism you think
about a kid chasing an ice cream truck
right whereas to be driven by need is
defense it's it's it's scared right and
it's fear based it's fear-based you're
not as capable actually so when people
set themselves up to chase a goal it's
important to have your basic needs met
so that the goal chasing
isn't your livelihood it's really I mean
that's a privilege to create that I know
some people do quite well with needing
something but I think it's nice when you
can do it out of a place of curiosity
right there's a purity to it that way
yeah well and you can have a sense of
humor about I don't know like think
about when you like play on the
playground like if someone like trips
you but you're like chasing a boy like
you're still going to go after the boy
you can kind of like I think you have
more ability to to handle hurdles when
you're coming from a curious place cuz
it's all good it's not result oriented
it's you're looking at like a whole
Horizon instead of like a pin point or
something yeah well I also think to the
point of of separating your goals and
aspirations from your financial needs
keeps you on track from a
decision-making perspective with respect
to those goals because if your finances
are dependent upon them then you're and
you're going to end up making decisions
that maybe are positive in the short run
but ultimately sacrifice the larger
thing that you're trying to achieve yeah
but sports are a good example of things
that like feel life or death but we know
they aren't right yeah no I'm just
thinking of again I'm like going back to
Arnold schwarzen here because it's just
top of my mind but one of the things
that he did when he decided that his
goal was to become this big movie star
action star was to not have his
livelihood dependent upon his acting
career so he he had all this real estate
he developed like a real estate business
and owned all these properties so that
he had plenty of money and he didn't
have to make decisions about um
auditions or shitty you know projects
because he needed the money right and he
could just say no I'm I'm going for this
thing over here so I'm not going to do
what all these other working actors have
to do because their livelihood is
dependent upon booking roles okay how
that really would play into it is when
your livelihood does not depend on it
then when you need to make like a risky
decision or a brave decision or whatever
it's not as risky it's not as risky and
I I've been thinking a lot about this
thing which I call like the infinite
unknown which is like just that we
fixate on the things we know because
it's the only thing we can actually
visualize and how this plays out is like
let's just say you're a little your hip
is a little banged up and you're going
into a race
and maybe you're deciding whether you
race or not the thing you know is you've
run maybe you've run this race before
you know what it feels like to win or
run a personal best that's all you're
thinking about but what you're not
thinking about is the bad infinite
unknown in this example of how bad that
hip could be if you do run like most
people don't fixate on that they think
about the loss of the race that they can
visualize because they've run before the
proper decision would be to respect that
you infinitely do not know how bad your
hip could get and you should not race
but the positive infinite known would be
like let's just say you're um yeah
you're you're making a decision between
two career choices or whatever or maybe
Arnold Schwarzenegger had a conservative
decision or risky one but the
conservative one is more something he
can visualize like staying the course
because he knows where he's at the
infinite andn in the positive way would
be like the infinite wonderful
opportunities that he can't visualize
cuz he's never been there it's taking a
risk when you're not feeling financially
dependent on these decisions you can
make infinitely unknown decisions
without knowing where it's going to lead
more safely mhm it just you can do
scarier things yeah yeah yeah no I get
it I get it I like that it's hard though
it's like a privileged thing to be able
to untether like your dreams and your
Ambitions from your financial needs you
have to have your Basics covered yeah
which is like you have to know what your
Basics are right I want to change
subjects and talk a little bit about
mentorship and we alluded to it a little
bit earlier mentorship is a huge thing
with you you talk about it all the time
and you have lots of mentors for all
different areas of your life which I
think is beautiful and something I would
advise everybody to do and seek out in
their own life um but it's so meaningful
to you that you like are going to do a
podcast on this subject matter is this
correct this is correct
so there's a chapter in bravy called The
MENTOR buffet and it's just that we are
allowed and privileged to
have as many mentors as we want whether
in real life or the imagined type from
podcasts or books or what whatever you
can invent them I guess and the podcast
is just talking to people that influence
us about people who influenced them and
think it will mostly be people who
positively mentored people that we love
and want to hear from but it can also be
challenging mentorship examples and I'm
so excited to be doing this with your
team and we have one episode that we've
recorded with Matthew mccon but we have
many many more to to explore together
it's super exciting um and I love the
conceit because it allows you to connect
with well-known people people and not
force them to answer questions about
their life per se but to talk about the
people that influence them the most
which I think is really fresh and
interesting and I would suspect
intriguing for the people that you're
trying to get on the show yeah because I
I feel like we might not know who
influenced everybody right because it
could be like their could be like a
teacher in their Elementary School it
could be someone we know was a big
figure in their life but we haven't
heard much about mhm and I'm interested
in it
because I just want more
information it's not that useful to
follow what people do it's more helpful
to understand how they think and like
how they make decisions and so I think
probably this will lend itself to
learning more about how they think and
who influenced their thinking in turn we
will I will learn more and everyone will
and I I like that it's it's celebrating
the idea of mentorship not in the
context of fancy names and people we've
heard of but through the anonymous
people that have influenced the people
that we know about the third grade
teacher or the high school volleyball
teacher the you know the the Drama
teacher and Junior High or whatever it
is those people that you know influence
us in ways beyond what they probably
could ever have imagined you know that
becomes an indelible part about how that
person thinks about their life and
possibility yeah influence is like what
people say to you like there's influence
in the way of like advice and there's
also like influence in the way of
presence like some people are your
mentors because you get to watch them
move through the world they might may
say nothing it may be someone you've
only ever seen
always do some action that you know
always turn left very sharply like I
don't know just the way they are in the
world the way that they comport
themselves and you know as an example
that they're not even aware that they're
influenc
you but they are just by their being
yeah so hopefully it's not just like
these um here's what you're going to do
yeah exactly exactly it's like we can't
choose what influences us either right
like it either does or it doesn't
someone could say something to you
that's super profound and it means
nothing to you but something else might
resonate for reasons an off-handed
comment by somebody else stays with you
your whole life yeah yeah so I'm I'm
really really excited and uh it feels
very true to my interest and to a gap in
the world that like this this Buffet
should be for everybody and what's it
called Mentor Buffet of course it Mentor
Buffet I love it cool well I got to let
you go but um the last thing I want to
ask you about is the new bravy for young
people like why did you decide to create
a new different version of of your
wonderful Book for a younger audience so
the bravy adapted for young readers
which is a long time it was a fun
project to try to not just truncate a
book but tried to make it tailored
towards an audience that I think can use
some of this like wisdom in a simplified
version uh in a way that I would have
liked that's an answer that I think is
obvious but it's still true and it's
much more instructional and much less
memoir so less of my life more of the
like the goods that you might keep in
your pocket for advice and Maya Hawk
wrote the forward which I'm really
excited about yeah she speaks about you
know like her dyslexia and things I
can't speak to but still like challenges
growing up well first of all let's let's
just like highlight the fact that like
you got both of the Maya to write
forward you got Maya Rudolph or Maya
Rudolph wrote the forward to bravy right
and now you have my HW for the other one
I'm obsessed with her dad by the way but
that's a different thing a very cool I
would imagine part of it is is motivated
by the fact that you know young girls
drop out of Sports at a young age at
like you know pretty high rate when
compared to young teenage boys twice the
rate of boys by the age of is that high
mhm wow hopefully it'll change but
probably the reason why one of the
reasons why girls drop out of sports
younger is because like being a female
an adult female athlete it felt to me as
a kid at least as like a very polarizing
decision like you either were or you
were not whereas with men I felt like
growing up I saw more adult men playing
sports pickup whatever you just I just
saw it more and so to show more female
adult athletes playing will hopefully
make it seem less like you're deciding
to either be an athlete or not at such a
young age and make it less of like a
practical decision and more of like a
possible life you could have in
conjunction with whatever dream you have
you know yeah yeah so it's cool I want
you to close with the the chapter or the
section in the book about glp oh glop
can you talk about glp yeah so goop is
my favorite chapter in the book and it
represents uh knowled that I gained
since writing bravy which was a fun
thing to like update what I knew in the
world and glp is just the idea that uh
scientifically when caterpillars become
butterflies they go into a chrysalis and
they don't just Sprout wings but they
are actually reduced down to a liquid
form complete and total liquid called
unscientifically glp and then they
become a butterfly and what I identified
with so strongly is that when I'm going
through change when any of us are going
through
change we might be reduced down to our
lowest goop State we might not feel
great and that's not a bad thing and
anytime I felt like I was glop I usually
try to revert back and become a
caterpillar again and put myself back
together but to look at science as
inspiration I think is really empowering
because you can celebrate GOP and decide
to move forward and become a butter fly
and humans are unlike caterpillars in
that we can choose to stay caterpillar
forever and we do feel the pain of Glop
Hood so caterpillars are unconscious in
their crysalis but we are not so I think
the metaphor and the chapter is
important to me
because we should feel that glp is good
and if you're feeling like GOP you can
celebrate it as a non- negotiable stage
that you have to go through to become
something else yeah yeah and you can
print it on a shirt and say I'm glop and
wear it around like a prideful label
which if you haven't done already you
probably are doing I put it on a
sweatshirt when I was glob but no it's
fun because uh kids uh people should
tell kids you can't predict your life it
will always surprise you and that
change is is hard in in a way that is
actually like
normal you know yeah that's really
important I mean and that that goes to
your reflex towards like actionable
tools to use as opposed to feel better
or it'll be fine but like no what can I
actually do I can shake my arms out or I
can like what what is behavioral well
and also there's so much dialogue now
that says like it's okay if you don't
feel great today if you do nothing and
like I understand that I think it's
important to allow people their like
like recovery days and mental health
days but like when when you are feeling
like glp the thing that will move you
forward is not just patience and time
but also action to become a
butterfly yeah not just wallowing in the
glob yeah exactly trying to Usher the
glob into the butterfly right yeah yeah
we're active in our states are actively
engaged in our own glo-like states with
our glop yeah I'm imagining you as like
a green like a green blob in there it's
your face but you're just a blob I've
been there um well doesn't get better
than that I think that's where we have
to end it today I love you that was
fantastic such a champion of who you are
and everything you're doing and uh I
just love talking to you so thank you
I'm very grateful for you I have called
you when I've been very confused and
you've been very succinct and direct and
that I am really grateful for too that's
sweet I appreciate that bravy for the
young reader is that the for young
readers is that how you say it properly
great yeah and the movie is coming out
not for another year right winter spring
2024 like NE next soon all right well in
the meantime lots of glitter and glamour
on the road and on the trail for you my
friend yes all right I'll see you out
there to be continued to be continued
all right Mentor Buffet coming soon too
Mentor Buffet coming soon
peace
BL that's it for today thank you for
listening I truly hope you enjoyed the
conversation to learn more about today's
guest including links and resources
related to everything discussed today
visit the episode page at Rich roll.com
where you can find the entire podcast
archive as well as podcast merch my
books Finding Ultra voicing change and
the plant power way as well as the plant
power meal planner at meals. ritual.com
if you'd like to support the podcast the
easiest and most impactful thing you can
do is to subscribe to the show on Apple
podcasts on Spotify and on YouTube and
leave a review and or comment supporting
the sponsors who support the show is
also important and appreciated and
sharing the show or your favorite
episode with friends or on social media
is of course awesome and very helpful
and finally for podcast updates special
offers on books the meal planner and
other subjects please subscribe to our
newsletter which you can find on the
footer of any page at Rich roll.com
Today's show was produced and engineered
by Jason Cameo with additional audio
engineering by Kale Curtis the video
edition of the podcast was created by
Blake Curtis with assistance by our
creative director Dan Drake portraits by
Davey Greenberg Gra traffic and social
media assets courtesy of Daniel CIS
thank you Georgia Wy for copywriting and
website management and of course our
theme music was created by Tyler Patt
Traer Patt and Harry mathys appreciate
the love love the support see you back
here soon peace plance
[Music]
namaste
he